okay so this is how to evaluate startup
ideas and this is actually a new set of
content that we've developed based on a
lot of feedback that we saw from the
last startup school and what we noticed
is a lot of people's challenges so last
year's curriculum actually had a lot of
content that ended up being when we
looked at the data for who's
participating in startup school was like
oh this is much more advanced it's much
further along a lot of people for
instance like I had no idea or like I
have too many ideas that they don't know
which one to pursue it was a main reason
why a lot of people are only able to
work on their startup sometimes
part-time yes they might be stuck but
that resources but they didn't have
conviction they didn't know like oh what
would I have to believe in order to say
like I want to quit my job this is also
a really great sort of skill to sort of
have because if you are realizing you
need to pivot how do you evaluate if you
need to do that and then also if you're
pivoting to something else like how do
you evaluate whether something is worth
going to and if you already have a
launch company then you might have
problems with like why isn't this
growing or how do i improve it and
evaluating your startup especially in a
way that sort of adventures evaluate
startups ideas we find it's going to be
really really useful there's just like
myth about Y Combinator is that people
think YC only funds companies who have
tons and tons of traction right that
nowadays the only way to get into IC you
have to have lots of revenue or tons of
users already and part of that has to do
with like the press and then the
exposure of the companies that make it
the demo day those are the stories you
tend to hear but that being said there's
lots of great examples of companies who
actually got accepted just with an idea
and so zenefits is a really good classic
one Parker was a single non-technical
founder who pitched an idea to YC and he
got in that way we also had reddit so
technically they were forced to pivot
right away so they hadn't written a
single line of code and then my
experience in in YC is actually exactly
the same so when I founded wafu and we
entered that second
we also had not written a single line of
code PG had invested us at just the idea
stage and so I feel fully committed now
as a partner to always be trying to find
and dedicate time and energy to funding
companies we're just at the idea stage a
lot of our efforts here for working on
startup school is to help us help you
work on how to talk and think about your
startup and that if we can fix that it
can help you sort of inspire us to be
like oh yeah I can believe in what
you're doing and a lot of times founders
get in the way when they're telling
their narrative so how can I predict if
an investor will like my ideas that's
ultimately what we're trying to figure
out and the answer is really easy and so
for us at YC the definition of a
start-up is a company that is designed
or created to try to grow very quickly
so if you're not trying to build a
company that grows very very fast then
you're just building a normal company
it's a small business and there's
nothing wrong with that but these
companies are the ones that investors
are interested in so if you look hoping
to build something that will have tons
of users that will have huge valuations
that'll be able to attract venture
funding then the evidence that we want
is evidence that shows that your company
can grow quickly I have a confession to
make if you ever meet me or talk to me
about your startup and kind of
recruiting or at one of these events I
will never tell you that I do not like
your idea and there's a reason for that
is not to be nice to you is not to blow
smoke up your ass
I learned this way of thinking from Paul
Graham he says like look the average
investor or a lot of investors that you
see when you talk to them about your
idea it feels like they're trying to
poke holes in your idea they're trying
to figure out what's wrong with it and
then I like trying to show some not just
how smart they are and he explained that
like his job in the way he sees our work
at YC is that it's not to figure out
what's wrong with the company
but to figure out how it could possibly
win because our bets the ones that win
are the ones that are non-obvious right
and so for us to figure out the
non-obvious stuff it's good it's not
sound obvious when they first tell you
and so we have to like work on our
imagination we have to work on our
optimism to figure out what is the way
that whatever story that they're telling
me could become a billion dollar company
and then a great investor pitches that
back to the founder I figure out all the
ways that I think whatever you're doing
could possibly become big and then I'm
trying to convince you that this is what
needs to happen so that I would have the
evidence or that you will be on the
right path to having company that grows
quickly a start-up idea is basically a
hypothesis and this is the way you
should think about it it's a hypothesis
about why a company could grow quickly
and your job is to figure out how to
construct your hypothesis basically the
pitch to the investor so they understand
how it can go grow quickly a lot of
times people make the mistakes of trying
to just accurately describe or over
describe a lot of different parts so I'm
gonna break it this down so just like a
normal hypothesis has a pretty decent
structure for this this will hopefully
help you sort of workshop like
understanding oh this is exactly all the
reasons why this should succeed and so
even before we start even building
anything we can have an understanding of
like oh here's the potential path of
this company or here's the things I need
to prove the show that this company
could do well so the first is the
problem so startup idea is composed of
three parts the first part is a problem
and it's basically the initial
conditions you have to explain to me
like what is the setting for this
company that allows it to be able to
grow quickly the second is the solution
so this is basically what is the
experiment that you're basically running
within those conditions for it to grow
really quickly and the third is what's
your insight so what's your explanation
why the thing that you're going to try
your experiment is going to end up
successful those are the three
components that are always trying to
figure out when I'm listening to
someone's pitch here's a tip for talking
about the problem or to know whether
your problem your initial conditions are
correct the first is good problems
they're popular so a lot of people have
the problem you want to avoid problems
that there's a small number of people
that have it
we like problems that are growing so
therefore the market basically like is
it growing at a rate that's like more
and more people going to be having the
problem and it's it's growing faster
than other people's or other types of
problems we like problems that are
urgent ones that need to be solved very
very quickly we like problems that are
really expensive to solve because if
you're able to sort of solve it then you
can charge a lot of money potentially we
like problems that are mandatory right
so therefore it's like ah people have
this problem and they have to solve it
and then we like problems that are
frequent ones that people are gonna
encounter over and over and over again
and often in a frequent time interval so
what you want to have is like some
aspect of the problem that you're
working on at least one of them and
that's ideal if you have multiple of
them you don't have to have all of them
but it's one of those things where it's
like if your company isn't growing or if
someone's not as excited about the
problem it's probably missing some of
these characteristics the last one about
frequency is super important because I
like problems and you'll find a lot of
other YC partners like problems a lot
that gives people a lot of opportunities
to convert part of that has to do with
some theory so BJ Fogg he's a researcher
at Stanford and he tosses his formula up
all the time I mean he says basically if
you're trying to change someone's
behavior you have three things you need
to have in place you need to have the
motivation the ability and the trigger
they need to all happen at the same time
so the motivation is like I have this
problem I need to solve what is it
whatever it is the ability is your
startup and the last is the trigger
what's going to be the thing that gets
them to all of a sudden realize Oh
need to solve it with your thing and so
a lot of companies will have like oh I
built something but for some reason no
one's signing up or like they're not
using it they're not engaged I have no
retention and a lot of times is because
it's like you're hoping that they will
somehow just remember on their own that
they have the problem and to start using
you and oftentimes most companies don't
send enough for example email
notifications or triggers or reminders
or figure out ways to come back into the
app or figure out ways to be back in
front of the user at the right time and
if you can't figure out those
opportunities it's really hard to get
people to switch over to using your
solution service or product so our ideal
problems are millions of users right
millions of people have it that's why
people like to work on consumer
companies it's why some investors like
to focus on them we like markets that
are growing 20% a year the problem is
growing quickly we like problems where
people are trying to solve it right now
immediately we like problems that just
cost a ton of money so billions of
dollars right or at least they all add
up to some billion dollar total
addressable market we like problems
where the law has changed the law has
changed and regulation has put up there
and now people have to solve a bunch of
problems you saw a ton of healthcare
problem healthcare startups were born
after Affordable Care Act was passed and
a lot of that had to do with like there
was now all the sudden opportunity this
problem that all these hospitals and
clinics had to solve and then we like
problem is that people need to solve
multiple times a day or will use it
multiple times a day
Facebook's a good classic example but
people also really loves to slack right
because it's like oh I'm gonna be
engaged and using it multiple times a
day during the wait work day solution so
there's pretty much only one piece of
advice I really have for this solution
that's the best advice that you can ever
follow and that is don't start here so
what I mean by that is a YC we have an
acronym for a problem that we try to
avoid or basically an application
we have to go like oh man I wish they
had started with the problem first and
we call it sis P it means solution and
search of a problem and often what
happens is like you're an engineer
you're excited about technology some new
technology has come on the scene let's
say it's blockchain right let's say it's
like react native or whatever the new
thing is and you're like I want to build
something with this it's a large reason
why you start working on a side project
and then you go like okay what kind of
problem can I solve now I'm gonna use
this no matter what and then you try to
shoehorn a problem into the solution and
what ends up happening is that's a much
more difficult way to grow the company
it's not impossible for companies to
grow this way it's super inefficient
it's much better to be like let me see
what problems people have and then I
will use whatever is necessary to solve
them and therefore it's much more likely
that you will grow as a result because
the other way around is you might have
to go and try to drum up the problem or
you have to like brand the problem as
something that people have and it's so
much more difficult you end up growing
much more slowly as a result so look at
what you're building right now or look
at the reason why you're trying to do
this startup and is it because you only
care about the technology and building
something in that or have you started
with the problem you go like I'm gonna
do whatever it takes to solve people
users customers issues the last one's a
little tricky it's what is the inside
what's the reason why this solution is
going to work and this is where a lot of
companies sort of get tricked up because
it's really about like what is your
company's unfair advantage right why are
you gonna win versus everyone else why
are you going to be the fastest one to
sort of grow because that insight is
what's needed for the investor to choose
you over anyone else and it has to be
related to growth you have to have an
unfair advantage that explains why
you're going to grow quickly if it's not
related to that then it's not it's not
going to be something that an investor
is going to find valuable and the last
one is you need one you you can't just
be like I have a problem I'm solving it
and it had
no explanation why without that last
sort of explanation I can't use my
imagination
I can't evaluate just solely on how well
you've thought through this problem all
right and so let's go through the types
of unfair advantages that your company
have so there's five different types and
companies do not have all of them really
great ones surprising not surprising
we'll have all of them and we'll go
through two examples but you want at
least one and it's nice if you can have
two or three but for most of you it's
probably just one so the first one so
how do you know if you have a founder
unfair advantage and so all of these
will be connected to numbers actually
which will help this make this really
easy it's like are you one in ten of all
the people in the world who can solve
this problem are you super expert and
99% of the people we find out why see do
not fall into that category and so if
you think it's like well I'm a product
manager at Google there's a lot of
product managers at Google if you say
you're an engineer at Microsoft there's
a lot of engineers at Microsoft it's
like great but it's not one that will
make me think oh you have a grater on a
very understanding someone else if
you've done a PhD and let's say you've
done it on some kind of crazy biotech
research and you have like a special
patent to be able to cure some kind of
disease then you have a founder
advantage your market is it growing 20%
a year like by default if you just build
the solution in the space you should
just automatically grow because you're
just following a trend if this is your
only company advantage then it's one of
the weakest ones that you could have it
is great to be in that space but you
want to have something in addition to
this like you're gonna do like better
than average because you've picked the
right problem space and the right set of
customers that want your problem but
again if you're in a market that is
stagnating or shrinking
then you're gonna have investors worried
about the long-term viability every
company as a result product so super
simple is your product 10x better than
the competition
if it is then you potentially have an
unfair advantage and has to be very very
clear someone should be able to look at
your product and go like oh [ __ ] this is
so much better than everything else I've
ever seen it is 10x faster it is 10x
cheaper etc and if it's not an order of
magnitude let's say it's just like 2x or
3x again that's nice but it's not enough
for an investor to go like oh this is a
slam dunk in regards to that 10x product
and showing that you are able to have
that a later in startup school going to
do a lecture on pricing and we'll talk
things about cost and value and that'll
help you sort of better understand it's
like oh how to better prove out that 10x
multiple using sort of metrics and
numbers and pricing acquisition so a lot
of people think that if you go to
investor and you've done a bunch of
Facebook or Twitter or Google Ads and
you show your CAC and an LTV that you
were able to prove that you have a
sustainable sort of acquisition model
and I want you to know that if paid
acquisition is the only way that you
were able to grow your company then I'm
gonna discount that channel of growth
greatly that is because if you actually
get really popular you can actually
start being someone significant let's
say becoming a hundred million dollar
revenue company then you're gonna
attract a lot of competitors into the
space and that advantage is going to
quickly dwindling is a really good
example of this almost all their
acquisitions isn't paid and then once
they ate through that there's almost
nowhere else for them to sort of go you
want to find acquisition paths that cost
no money and my favorite companies the
ones that become really great are the
ones that can grow by word-of-mouth this
is a good percentage of the way they
grow and so in the early days of your
startup if you don't have any money
that's actually very great way of
exercising how do I grow this without
having to pay for it and so in the
beginning we tell you to do things that
don't scale
but this is what you sort of want to
accomplish it's like do I have an
advantage that is free and the last one
is do you do you have a monopoly and so
we don't mean this in the monocle
monopoly game sense so we made it as
like as your company grows is it more
difficult for you to be defeated by
competitors do you get stronger and so a
good examples of that are like companies
with Network effects in marketplaces
where marketplaces where it tends to be
a winner-takes-all a one company will
tend to win and network effects is just
basically as my network grows the
strength of my company and the value of
the product or service also grows with
it
not every company has it well when you
do have that it works out great there's
something to keep in mind also other
things I'm looking to believe about a
company and that is something that trips
up a lot of founders and so there's two
types of beliefs that I have about a
company and so there's the threshold
belief which is like what's the default
just for them to even succeed so
oftentimes for me it's like oh then
building it can they even built it
that's a threshold belief if they can't
even build it none of it even matters
and so to me that question is not the
most important what will determine
whether I'm gonna win the lotto
it's a miracle belief that like oh my
god if I believe that they can do this
that actually going to be able to take
off really well and sometimes are really
simple so if you are heavy engineering
team or doing a B DB or Enterprise
startup again the default is you have to
build it so if you can't even build it
then it's not even gonna work so I don't
spend actually a lot of time looking at
that for me I'm trying to figure out
success will be determined by how well
you can do sales how well you can tell
the story how well you can actually
convince customers and work through a
sales process I want evidence that shows
that you know how to work through that
and make that happen and so all of my
work with most of those companies is
like not working on product it's like
hey alright let's prove this other thing
if you have that that'll be the thing
that actually will help people go like
oh [ __ ] they have this super combo let's
go some some quick examples so YC is a
good one because we like to think of YC
as a startup so the problem the way we'd
word this is it's hard for founders to
raise money without knowing someone in
venture capital so at the time it was
started you basically had to be an
insider it was the only way you can sort
of get money and that's super sucked and
the solution that basically Paul Graham
came up with is like investing companies
through an open application you don't
need to know anyone you just tell us
your idea tell us a bit about yourselves
and that should be enough for you to get
funding now there's a bunch of unfair
advantages that YC had number one the
founders are pretty incredible so Paul
Graham had wrote a textbook on Lisp RTM
like wrote the very first worm he's like
amazing programmer and they had built
and sold the first SAS company that was
via web to Yahoo so they were kind of
experts at both evaluating technology
and also understanding kind of starts in
that whole process the market basically
believed that future billion-dollar
companies would be technology companies
they'd be powered by software and the
wonderful thing about tech companies
especially at that time was Moore's law
was making it cheaper and cheaper for
software companies to be started and
they furred they needed a whole lot less
money and he could make a lot more bets
as a result the product so basically you
know they pay the founders that come for
three months they get some advice they
work on their product for a relatively
small amount of money and then at the
end of the time instead of offering
co-working space they work from their
own home and then they pitch to a bunch
of different investors and the idea was
like that would be so valuable to a
potential founder who had no connections
that it would attract a lot of really
great
or a lot of people who were hungry to
get into the space acquisition so most
people don't realize this is like PG was
able to sort of build up YC and attract
the right talent because he had a huge
reach or audience when he got started he
had written that textbook yes but he
also brought all these popular online
essays and had a large audience of his
target users hackers to come and
evaluate his product and you can acquire
them relatively cheaply just by baking a
website and letting it be known and then
the last one is something he didn't even
realize when he started YC and that is
that as the YC alumni network grew it
got more powerful and more valuable over
time the results are funded 2,000
companies there's 4,000 founders they're
the CEOs of some of the biggest
companies in the world they are over 15
companies worth a billion dollar a
billion dollars
there's 93 companies with over 100
million dollars and our total market
capitalization is over a hundred billion
dollars I'm gonna do one more example
with you guys so we flew this was my
startup and it's an online forum and
survey builder and so for us it was
basically every website needs to collect
some kind of data at some point but you
need to know how to code or hire a
programmer to be able to do it and so
the solution was to build something that
what they see is what they got like
basically a drag-and-drop visual editor
and that any non-technical person sort
of create and then if we did that we
would solve that sort of specific
problem so very quickly the market it's
kind of ridiculous like we were asked in
the early days calculate our Tam but it
was like every website needs I don't
really understand like what website
doesn't need a forum eventually it
allowed us to grow really really quickly
our product was easily shown to be 10x
faster and it's against the direct
competition with other builders because
it was so much faster to do the drag and
dropping and visually see and then
usually a hundred X faster than like a
lot of traditional routes for very
custom forums for hiring a programmer
and very cheaper because we had this
freemium model
that also led to an acquisition unfair
advantage and so we actually had started
off with building a blog and building an
audience as well
started off with a hundred thousand
developers subscribe to our blog we
launched it out to them after building
up that audience for a year and that's
actually what we applied to YC with it's
like we had built up this audience we
had proved that all these other things
are like in place and then part of the
other acquisition model is that you
could embed these forms on people's
websites and then our users basically
spread our form and software for us as a
result so we never had that hire any
salespeople and the results are our
product was used by every industry
market and vertical you can imagine the
homes of super large companies and we
did this with a relatively small amount
of team when we were acquired we were
weird outlier compared to all the other
acquisitions the average company raises
only raises like twenty five million
dollars before an exit and this is their
average return and for Ruffo we only
raised 118 thousands for the whole life
of the company and our returns are over
thirty thousand percent okay so in the
end this is very simple exercise but
super enlightening once you actually go
through it and to try to figure out that
narrative and story so I turn it back to
you go through and try to answer those
questions about problems solution your
unfair advantage figure out where are my
holes do I have one and then the
question becomes Oh what do I need to
prove what do I need to work on to make
that happen your startup idea is a
hypothesis about why you're going to
grow quickly for our next lecture we're
gonna talk about the first ways we try
to prove it out so to basically test our
hunches and that is by talking to users
you